type that were gonna deal with is the
general form this is the y equals ax
squared plus bx plus c form and our
example number one y equals negative
three x squared plus 6x plus one we want
to find that vertex and the way you find
the vertex is using this formula right
here you might want to write this down
and memorize it it's x equals negative b
over 2a so that negative b over 2a is
giving us the x-coordinate of the vertex
so let's go ahead and do that so we've
got the opposite of b so by the way so
this is a b and c right so ax squared
plus bx plus c unfortunately the six
actually looks like a b but that's just
coincidence right so it's the opposite
of B so negative 6 over 2 times a which
is negative 3 so negative 6 over
negative 6 equals positive 1 and if we
take that one and we put it back into
our equation okay for X we can solve for
the y-coordinate of the vertex
now remember parabola is this u-shaped
graph right and the vertex is that point
where it changes directions so that's a
key point on the graph so if we take the
1 let's put it back in we get negative 3
times 1 squared plus 6 times 1 plus 1
equals y 1 squared is 1 times negative 3
is negative 3 6 times 1 is 6 plus 1 so
we get 7 minus 3 is 4 so you can see the
vertex is going to be at 1 comma 4 okay
so here with me so far so we're gonna go
right 1 up four that's our vertex right
there 1 4 and the other thing you can do
is with this type here the y equals x
squared type as you can draw a vertical
line like this through that vertex
that's called the axis of symmetry and
it's going to be this negative B over 2a
in this case x equals 1 remember x
equals lines are vertical lines and so
then at this point now all we have to do
is find some other key points and I'm
gonna show you a couple different ways
to find those key points one way to find
some key points is to look at this C
value right here okay the C value is the
y-intercept and the reason it's the
y-intercept is because you know when you
set X to 0 that's how you find the
y-intercept so by putting a 0 in for X
is going to cancel out these terms and
you can see that the Y value is 1
okay so you can see here at zero comma
one we've got another point on our graph
and the nice thing about the axis of
symmetry is if you've reflected over
that line you're gonna get another point
on your graph okay now another technique
that teachers often show you is to focus
in on this first part of the equation
the y equals ax squared okay this is
oftentimes referred to as the parent
function and it gives you the basic
shape of the graph like how wide it is
or how narrow it is and whether it opens
up or down and then the whole equation
is you know gonna be involved with
shifting the graph up and down left and
right but this first part is really
going to be giving you the basic shape
of the graph okay
so what you can also do is make a table
okay like we started doing over here but
what I would do is just pick some small
values like one two and three so if we
put one in one squared is one times
negative three is negative three now
remember you want to follow the order of
operations a lot of students will say
negative three times one is negative
three and then square it in and that's
nine but that's not correct you want to
follow your PEMDAS your order of
operations look if we put two in we get
2 squared is 4 times negative 3 is
negative 12 if we put 3 + 3 squared is 9
times negative 3 is negative 27 but
here's the key you want to graph these
points from the vertex so you're going
to pretend like this vertex is like your
origin or your new starting point so
from here I'm going right 1 down 3
that's this point here okay we already
found those you can also go right to
down 12 ok and so I'm just gonna
estimate let's say it's way down over
here if you take the mirror image over
that line of symmetry ok this vertical
line here you're gonna get the
corresponding point and then of course
if I go right 3 down negative 27 that's
all the way down to the floor right but
in any case you can see when I draw this
it's opening down and we knew that
because the a value here is negative so
when it's negative it tells you that the
graph is opening down if it's positive
it opens up and that's your graph so
let's look at another example see if you
can do this one on your own and we'll go
through it together so example number
two we've got y equals 2x squared plus
8x plus 6 so what do you think how would
you graph that well first things first
let's go ahead and find the vertex so
negative B over two times a right so the
opposite of B remember this is B this is
a this is C so we've got negative 8 over
2 times a which is 2 negative 8 over 4
is negative 2 right so we've got
negative 2 now we have to find out what
the y-coordinate of the vertex is so
we're going to put negative 2 back in
for X so let me see if I can do that
here for it 2 negative 2 squared plus 8
times negative 2 plus 6 so negative 2
squared is 4 times 2 is 8 right 8 times
negative 2 is negative 16 plus 6 more so
we got negative 10 Plus 8 which is
negative 2 okay so our vertex is at
negative 2 negative 2 so left 2 down 2
I'm going to draw that axis of symmetry
okay right through the vertex and then
now what we want to do is find some
other key points so if we look at our C
value okay remember C value is this
number here at the end that's going to
be 6 that tells us that the graphs can
be crossing up here at 1 2 3 4 5 6 and
notice how I'm like 2 units from the
axis of symmetry so if I go to on the
other side I'm going to be at that same
height okay
now let's pick out some other values
like say for example we make a table
like this X comma Y and I'm just
focusing in on this parent function so
say for example I put 1 in 1 squared is
1 times 2 is 2 so from this vertex right
here I'm gonna go right 1 up 2 and I can
do the mirror image over that line of
symmetry so now you can see we're
getting a nice graph it's opening up
which we knew that was gonna happen
because the a value is positive when the
graph opens up like this you're gonna
get a minimum value okay when the graph
opens down like this one you're gonna
get a maximum value you know a high
point and that minimum value is just
whatever the y-coordinate is it's
negative 2 in this case the maximum
value is the y-coordinate which was 4
right and then if they ask you for the
axis of symmetry that's this line right
here that's x equals negative B over 2a
in this case that's x equals negative 2
okay and that's basically it the only
other thing that might ask you is the
domain in the range in this case you can
see the domain is whatever the X values
can be and it's going to the left and
right you know forever and ever this is
going up but it's also expanding out
like that so the domain would be all
real numbers and then the range those
are the y-values so in this case you can
see the lowest that the Y values can be
here at negative 2 or higher so that's
going to be y is greater than or equal
to negative 2 okay so this is your basic
parabola this is using the y equals ax
squared plus bx plus c form the general
form the next one we're to look at is
the intercept form okay this next type
of parabola that we're going to be
graphing and working with is the
parabola that's in this form y equals a
times the quantity X minus P times the
quantity X minus Q and notice it's like
in a factored form and this is called
the intercept form and the reason is is
because if you set these factors equal
to 0 you're going to be finding the
x-intercepts meaning where it crosses
the x axis okay so the way to recognize
this is it's in factored form so let's
look at example number 1 here of this
type you can see our a value is negative
1 and all that a value really represents
is that the parabola is opening down the
larger the a value is like if it was 2
or 3 or 4 it's gonna stretch it by 2 or
3 or 4 times which is gonna make the
graph on narrower whereas if this was
like 1/2 Earth you know third or fourth
would make it wider right but the
negative one here is making it open down
and we'll talk about this in just a
minute but if we set these factors equal
to 0 X minus 3 equals 0 X minus 5 equals
0 add 3 to both sides right and you can
see that x equals 3 and add 5 to both
sides here x equals 5
those are acts intercepts so let's go
ahead and graph those so 1 2 3 ok and 4
5 those are X intercepts now what you
want to do is you want to find the
middle between those two X intercepts
that's going to be your axis of symmetry
it's also going to be the x coordinate
of your vertex so in this case you can
see that it's gonna be right here at x
equals 4 okay so I'll just write that
down here x equals 4 and if you want a
formula you can use this guy right up
here x equals P plus Q divided by 2 so
it's like an average you would you take
the negative 3 I'm sorry positive 3 plus
5 and you would divide that by 2 so
that's going to be 8 divided by 2 which
is 4 so you're just a verging those
two values to get the middle you're
adding them up and dividing by two okay
then you take that x equals four and you
want to put it back in for X okay so if
I do that I get four minus three which
is 1 times the negative 1 in front four
minus five is negative one if we
multiply those together you can see
we're getting positive one so that tells
us that that's our y coordinate of our
vertex so that's going to be at four
negative I'm sorry four positive one
right so right there so already we have
a pretty good set of points here we can
see our graph is looking like this okay
it's opening down it's turning right at
this vertex point four one we know it's
a maximum right because it's opening
down but if you want to get some
additional points what you can do is a
couple of different things one thing is
you can look at this a value and we can
kind of go back to what we were talking
about at the very beginning of this
lesson the y equals ax squared okay
that's what gives us the shape of the
graph that's our parent graph so in this
case our y equals negative 1 x squared
that's the basic shape of our graph if
we make a table okay and set some easy
values in here like got 1 2 3 some small
values 1 squared is 1 times negative 1
is negative 1 2 squared is 4 times
negative 1 is negative 4 3 squared is 9
times negative 1 is negative 9 but we're
gonna plot these points from the vertex
that's the key not from the origin here
we're gonna treat the vertex like the
origin so let's see we've got right 1
down 1 right 2 down 4 1 2 3 4 and again
you can take the mirror image over the
axis of symmetry and same thing over
here right 3 down 9 it's kind of going
off my graph you're your teacher okay is
going to want you to have five points so
that's pretty good we've got the vertex
the two x-intercepts one additional
point and we reflected it over the X you
know the axis of symmetry so that was a
good problem let's try another one see
if you can pause the video and do this
one on your own to check your
understanding so we've got y equals 2
times X plus 2 times X minus 2 okay so
what do you think well remember the
first thing is to set these factors
equal to 0 so if we do that X plus 2
equals 0 that would be negative 2x minus
2 set that to 0 add to the other side
that's going to be
positive too so that means it's gonna be
crossing the x-axis here at negative two
and positive two okay now if we use our
formula people's Q divided by two if we
add these up and divide by two you can
see we're getting 0 over 2 which is 0 so
that means right here at 0 that's our
axis of symmetry okay that's the line if
you fold it over the parabolas gonna
match to itself like so writes a mirror
image now what do we do with that 0 well
we take that 0 that's the x-coordinate
of our vertex we put it back in for X
here so 0 plus 2 is going to give us 2 0
minus 2 is going to give us negative 2
and we have a 2 out in front okay I'm
just bringing this 2 down
if we multiply those together you can
see we're gonna get y equals negative 8
so our vertex is gonna be at 0 negative
8 so let's see 0 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 negative
8 now you can see we've got a pretty
good idea what the graph is going to
look like
we know it's opening up because the a
value is positive how can we find some
additional points well one way to do
this is just to use the original
equation and we can say well we're kind
of interested in maybe like say like
this point right here when x equals 1
just just a little bit either side of
the vertex so say for example if I put 1
in 1 plus 2 is 3 1 minus 2 is negative 1
and if we multiply this out we get
negative 6 so over here we're at 1
negative 6 and if I do the mirror image
across that line of symmetry we've got
another point we've got our requisite
five points right and you want to kind
of round it out you don't want to make
it look like a via that's the absolute
value graph you want this to be more
like a u so I could've done a little bit
better with rounding that out that's a
pretty good sketch of our graph so you
can see it has a minimum value because
it's opening up that minimum value is
the y coordinate of the vertex negative
8 the axis of symmetry is this line here
it's the line x equals 0 the domain is
all real numbers so you can see it's
going left and right without bound and
then the range is the Y values and the Y
values are greater than or equal to
negative 8 so this here was talking
about the intercept form we're going to
go on next to the vertex form okay so
now we're looking at the vert
form of a parabola and how to graph that
so you've got the form y equals a times
the quantity X minus H squared plus K
the vertex is at H comma K now the thing
to remember with this form is that the
number of this group with the ax that's
in the parenthesis with the ax that is
going to have the opposite sign when you
find the x-coordinate of the vertex
whereas the K value is going to have the
same sign if it's positive it's going to
be positive if this is Mike minus 2 it's
going to be negative 2 but this one if
it was X minus 3 that would actually be
positive 3 if it was X plus 3 then this
would be negative 3 so you have to
remember the one that's grouped with the
the X it has the opposite sign so let's
look at an example and you'll understand
how this works so this one here you can
see that the vertex is actually at
positive 1 C not negative 1 but positive
1 and this is the same positive 6 so our
vertex here is at 1 comma 6 let's plot
that so right 1 1 2 3 4 5 6 that's our
vertex ok notice that the a value is
negative that means it's opening down
like that giving us a maximum and if you
want to find some additional points what
you can do is again just focus on that
parent function the y equals ax squared
and in this case since a is negative 3
that's going to give us the shape of the
graph so I'm just gonna make a table
pick some easy values for X some small
values 1 squared is 1 times negative 3 2
squared is 4 times negative 3 is
negative 12 and the numbers already
getting large so I'm gonna stop there
but if I put one in I'm gonna treat the
vertex like the origin right this I'm
going to go right 1 from the vertex and
down 3 and if I do the mirror image over
this line of symmetry right it's gonna
be right here
okay and then over here to negative 12
if I go right to down 12 I'm just gonna
estimate it somewhere down there and I'm
gonna do the mirror image over the line
of symmetry so you can see this graph is
going down fairly quickly here okay
and that's the idea now what makes it go
down quick by the way is this a value
the larger this a value is C 3 it's
stretching it which makes the graph
narrower and if that's why it's going
down quickly
of course the negative means it opens
down we have a maximum which occurs at
our y coordinate of our vertex at 6
that's as high as it goes
but if we're doing the domain and the
range the domain is all real numbers
the range is y is less than or equal to
6
okay so a great job on that one by the
way also the axis of symmetry is x
equals 1 that's that vertical line that
you know divides the parabola on half so
let's go to example 2 see if you can do
this one on your own
I don't go through it so what do you
think the vertex is on this one ok if
you said negative 2 negative 5 you're
right remember it's the opposite of 2
that's negative 2 this one has the
opposite sign and this one has the same
sign so I like to plot the vertex first
so left 2 down 5 that's gonna be right
there we draw our axis of symmetry like
so okay that's what divides the parabola
in half we take the parent function
which is the y equals ax squared in this
case a is 4 so we're looking at y equals
4 x squared and we can plot some small
numbers so I put 1 and I get 1 squared
as 1 times 4 is 4 2 squared is 4 times 4
is 16 but what I'm going to do is I'm
going to go from the vertex I'm going to
go right one up for right there I'm
going to take the mirror image over that
line of symmetry I'm gonna stop there
normally I do graph 5 points but the
numbers are just getting quite large so
I'm just gonna stop there so you can see
in this one we have a minimum because
the a value is positive its opening up
that minimum value is at negative 5 the
domain is all real numbers and the range
is y is greater than or equal to
negative 5 so great job on that one the
last type they're going to look at are
these ones here the x squared equals 4p
Y and the y squared equals 4p X and
we're gonna understand those and look at
the focus the directrix etc okay our
fourth and last type that we're gonna be
talking about are the parabolas that are
in the form x squared equals 4p y Y or Y
squared equals 4p X now a more general
way to write these are like with an H
and a K and remember that H and the K
basically pick up the graph shift the
parabola left and right or up and down
the one this group with the ax will
shift it in the X Direction right the
horizontal direction the one this group
with the Y will shift it in the vertical
direction in the Y direction but
remember it's gonna have the opposite
effect so the one that's grouped in
parentheses with that variable is
actually going to shift it the opposite
so if it was y -2 last
think negative tumors shift to the left
but you're actually shifting right to
okay so just remember the number this
group with that associated variable has
the opposite effect on the graph so
let's look at the first example and I'll
kind of go through it as we do this but
actually before we do that let's take a
quick look at the basic shape of a
parabola we know it's that you shaped
graph right but when it's in this form
what we're looking at and we're focusing
on is a couple different things we're
focusing on the vertex of course that's
the point where the parabola changes
direction we're also focusing on the
focus okay that's this point here and
then this imaginary line here called the
directrix and the idea here is is that
if you pick any point on the parabola
okay so say for example this parabola is
going out like that say I pick a point
right there on the parabola if I measure
the distance from that point to the
focus and then from that point
perpendicular to the directrix those
distances will always be the same so as
you go further out of course the
distance to the focus is going to get
further but then the distance to the
directrix is also going to get further
and those distances are always gonna be
the same so technically what a parabola
is it's the set of points that are
equidistant from a given point called
the focus and a given line called the
directrix okay so it's a it's a mouthful
but let's see if I can break it down and
kind of show you how this works so in
the first example x squared equals 12 Y
right so what I want to do is I want to
match it up against this form right here
x squared equals 4p Y so I can set for P
equal to 12 divide will size by 4 and I
can see that P equals 3 now because this
parabola hasn't been shifted at all see
the h and the K are 0 that means that
our vertex is going to be at the origin
0 0 okay so they're with me so far now
because it's an x squared variety x
squared
ones are gonna open up or down if it's a
Y squared it's going to be opening to
the right or the left okay so do you
want to remember x squared up or down Y
squared left or right okay so in this
case because P is positive it's going to
be opening up like this so I'm going to
go from the vertex up 3 1 2 3 that's
going to be our focus and if I go down 3
1 2 3 that's going to be our directrix
you can
kind of think of the directorate's like
a deflector like it's deflecting the
parabola like it's going this way and
it's deflecting it okay so it always
opens away from the directrix towards
the focus okay so notice that this p
distance this focal distance is the same
from the vertex to the focus as it is
from the vertex to the directrix okay so
now we need to get some other points on
a graph to get a nice parabola graph and
the key here is is that the width okay
this is called a focal chord this width
at the level of the focus is going to be
four times P wide okay we said that P is
3/4 times P is 12 so at the level the
focus it's going to be 12 wide what you
can do is cut that 12 and a half from
the focus go right 6 let's see 1 2 3 4 5
6 and left 6 1 2 3 4 5 6 like that so
that gives us a width of 12 at the level
of focus of course the parabola is
getting wider and wider you know as the
as it goes right but at this height here
at this focus level that's how wide it
is it's 12 so that'll give you a pretty
good idea of what the graph is looking
like right there now if they ask you for
the equation the directrix you can see
that this is a horizontal line
that's a y equals line it's y equals
negative 3 we know the coordinates of
the focus and we know the vertex so
we've got a pretty good sketch there ok
let's look at another example
let's look at a y squared variety now so
Y squared tells us this opening to the
right or the left right this way or this
way it's negative so that tells us going
to open to the left if it was positive
it would open to the right we want to
find our p value so we're going to set
for p equal to negative 16 divided by 4
P is negative 4 you can see that this
hasn't been shifted at all or H and our
K right or H nor K are 0 0 because it
hasn't been shifted you don't see it you
know anything in parentheses group at
the X or the Y this should actually be X
here okay
there's a typo on my part okay so now
you can see the vertex is going to be
right here at the origin okay 0 0 and we
said it's opening to the left so we're
going to go 4 to the left 1 2 3 4 okay
that's our focus that's our vertex and
if we go the other side 4 that's our
directrix right there okay it's
deflecting that parabola in a sense it's
opening away from the directrix towards
the focus
and then at the level of focus it's
going to be 16 units wide so from the
focus I'm going to go up eight and down
8 to give us that width of 16 so let's
do that 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 and then down 1
2 3 4 5 6 7 8 right about there so that
gives us an idea about how wide our
parabola is we know what's opening to
the left because of the negative Y
squared Rati opens left or right but
left because of the negative this one
here o is x squared
ok so it was opening up or down up
because P was positive and the only
thing they might ask you is you know
what's the axis they will might ask you
the axis of symmetry which is actually
this line right here this is the line y
equals 0 if you fold the parabola over
the x axis it's going to match to itself
but remember the x axis is actually the
line y equals 0 but the directrix this
equation would be it's a vertical line
so it's going to be x equals 4 and
that's basically about it they might ask
you the domain and range domain is going
to be Y X is less than or equal to 0
remember the domain are the X values so
less than or equal to 0 but the graph is
going up and down so the range would be
all real numbers okay a little bit more
challenging one this is our last example
this one what do you think okay quick
quiz do you think it's going to open up
down left or right well notice it's x
squared right the why isn't squared it's
the X's squared that tells us going to
open up or down right okay but 4 is
positive so that means it's gonna open
up but this was a negative here would
open down so let's locate our vertex now
notice the number group of the X that's
the x coordinate of the vertex the one
group to the Y that's the y coordinate
okay don't want to confuse those it's
pretty easy to remember whatever's with
X is the X whatever is with Y is the Y
but remember they're the opposite signs
- to see X is positive to positive 1 the
y coordinate is negative 1 so write 2
down 1 that's our vertex sometimes I'd
like to just label it with a V or an F
for focus or D for directrix and we know
it's opening up now this value here we
have to set equal to 4 P so if we divide
by 4 P equals 1 remember it's in this
form right here right so you can see 4 P
equals 4 P equals 1 so because it's
opening up I'm going to go up 1 that's
our focus
that's our directrix okay and then
remember at the level to focus how wide
it is is going to be for P in this case
for P is 4 so at the level of focus I'm
going to go right to and left 2 that
gives me the width of our parabola and
we have a pretty good sketch at that
point now if they ask you for the axis
of symmetry that's the vertical line
here that divides a parabola on half
right x equals 2 the directrix is this
horizontal line here that's kind of
deflecting the parabola in a sense is
opening away from the directrix that's
the line y equals negative 2 and you've
got it so we went through a lot of
different types of forms of the parabola
I'll have links in the description below
to other videos I did specifically
talking about some of these different
types if you want more practice more
experience and that sort of thing and I
also want to mention if you're preparing
for the AC T or the SAT which I know a
lot of students are check out my huge AC
t-- math review video course and my huge
SAT math review video course I'll have
links in the description below you can
check those out there's free lessons so
you can get some benefit from those and
if it's a good fit for you you can check
out those courses a lot of students have
taken them and they've benefited them
when they taking the test and I'm sure
they'll benefit you too and that's about
it if you have any suggestions or
comments for me put them in the comments
below otherwise I look forward to
helping in the future videos and I'll
talk to you soon